with fewer music cataloges being
snatched up for large sums this year's
list of the highest paid dead
celebrities features a wide range of
artists and authors here are the seven
celebrities who have made the most from
beyond the grave in
2023 number seven Whitney Houston
Houston would have turned 60 years old
in 2023 her estate is simultaneously
celebrating its biggest year yet thanks
to a movie deal and several brand
collaborations in December the film
Whitney Houston I want to dance with
somebody hit the big screens grossing
nearly $60 million worldwide ma
Cosmetics released a makeup collection
with the Houston estate which is helmed
by her sister-in-law and primary wave in
February the W Hotel in Los Angeles was
briefly made over as the Whitney
hotel number six prince prince famously
called the afterworld quote a world of
never-ending happiness for his estate
and primary wave which owns a stake in
his master's royalties writer share name
and likeness that means releasing more
music since Prince is untimely demise
he's released three postumus albums this
month a remastered version of his 1991
album Diamonds and Pearls is dropping
the box set features 47 unreleased songs
and hours of neverbe seen concert
footage number five Charles M Shaws
Charlie Brown famously got rocks for
Halloween but the Shaws is reaping in
the dough the Peanuts Gang continued its
work with apple which now airs its
holiday specials with a line of digital
faces for the brands watches fans of
Snoopy lonus and Lucy can stock up on
branded cookware at William Sonoma
sneakers from Kuma and iglu coolers it's
almost better than a visit from the
Great
Pumpkin number four Dr Seuss young
readers still can't get enough of the
colorful books written and illustrated
by Dr theor Seuss gel sales of the books
make up a majority of his annual
earnings the rest comes from licensing
of his classic characters like the
Grinch the Cat in the Hat and The Lorax
and more number three Ray
manzer in one of this year's few major
catalog deals the deceased doors
keyboard player and living guitarist
Robbie ker jointly sold their rights to
the band's music to primary wave the
acquisition included rights to their
recorded music publishing trademarks and
Merchandising and related income John
Den and the estate of Jim Morrison
maintain their stakes in the group's
rights number two Elvis Presley though
Elvis left the building nearly 50 years
ago it's still good to be the king
graceand Presley's home in Memphis
Tennessee saw some 600,000 visitors in
the last 12 months and the estate has
multiple sources of income including
tickets and merchandise after the
January death of Elvis's only daughter
Lisa Marie Presley his ex-wife Priscilla
and granddaughter Riley Kio entered into
a contentious legal battle for control
of the two Estates Kio a 34-year-old
actress who stars in Daisy Jones and the
six ended up as the sole Trustee of both
number one Michael Jackson the King of
Pop returns to the top of this list for
the first time since 2019 thanks to the
Broadway hit MJ the musical which gross
some $85 million in ticket sales over
the last year Jackson also takes in cash
from the cir to solay show Michael W in
Las Vegas his earnings should continue
to rise earlier this year the estate
signed on to Michael a biopic about the
performer starring Jackson's nephew
Jafar